a tiny group of protesters seemingly
intent on irritating the ranks of police
officers
stationed to protect their precinct
and you will be arrested a short warning
and the officers moved in to arrest the
group ostensibly
for failing to observe a curfew that's
just begun in philadelphia
after two nights of demonstrations
violence and looting
it's clear the authorities had had
enough and were determined to bring back
order
but it's equally clear that much of the
black community here
while not supporting looting believe
that the prejudicial treatment of blacks
is an endemic issue that simply isn't
being addressed
he did not have to get shot 14 times
you understand you had two officers with
glocks
with loaded mags and a man with one
knife
all this man with his neck got his one
swing one jab
with two officers with backup coming it
was not necessary
his mother was out there this man died
in front of his kids and his mother
much of this part of the city was
flooded with police officers
hours before the curfew began all had
riot gear available to them
and they were stationed at every major
intersection on the main
shopping road well after two nights of
violence and
protests police have clearly decided to
change taxes and
actually on the street permanently
they've been here for hours you can see
them down
uh 52nd street they're also over here
pretty much every street corner for
about another mile or so from here has
got uh
groups of police like this they are
insisting
that their presence will be seen and of
course now
there is a curfew underway
the shooting of walter wallace jr and
the subsequent violence and protest
was threatening to get out of hand an
investigation into the incident
is underway the police say mr wallace
refused to put down a knife and was shot
the family say he was having a mental
breakdown and actually needed
medical treatment much of the community
affected by the violence agreed with the
demonstrations
but not with the law breaking and
looting
darlene burton volunteered to help with
a clear up she's imploring people
to avoid violence this will result in
nothing
nothing at all like it's one thing i
understand people are upset
i get it but this is not the way to
display your anger towards what's going
on
it's counterproductive
the issue is far from over with the
family in the community
waiting for answers as to what happened
and why
stuart ramsey sky news philadelphia